though they have years of experience
under their belts our MCU favorites
aren't immune to making mistakes on the
job such as a case for the cast of
Avengers ends game who goofed up a
handful of times while filming the
superhero blockbuster here are some of
our favorite endgame bloopers and
outtakes Oh Chris Pratt's arguably the
goofiest of the three Chris's in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the
charismatic guy who plays star-lord is
known for getting the giggles going on
sets even in a movie with as much
emotion and intensity as endgame while
preparing to face off against Thanos in
the film's epic third act
Pratt offers a hilarious piece of advice
to keep the actor safe during shooting
nobody poor hamstring later in the ends
game blooper reel Pratt provides more
laughs when he stops to fix his hair
between takes
fat Thor officially known as bro Thor
was a prominent part of ents game with
many arguing about the purpose and
potential negative consequences of
portraying the god of thunder with a
plumper physique an increased love for
beer and candy and a gloomy outlook on
life it turns out that sticking web
dodgy actor Chris Hemsworth in a fat
suit and a bunch of heavy prosthetics
allowed for many antics to happen while
shooting endgame including this funny
moment with a rocket racoon stand-in
Robert Downey jr. is a focus of many
ends game bloopers starting with the
slipper that occurred when he was
filming a scene at the shield base in
the 1970s while attempting to get his
hands on the tesseract after the
Avengers failed to retrieve it from 2012
New York everything goes mostly
according to plan with Tony Stark and
Steve Rogers doing their best to blend
in and complete their high-stakes
mission
Tony ends up making his way to the
tesseract snagging it sticking it in his
briefcase and heading back to the Year
2023 to load up the Avengers infinity
gauntlet and bring back the billions of
people with honors dusted in one take of
the scene in which Tony retrieves a
tesseract
Downey jr. reaches out to grab the
glowing blue cube that holds a space
stone and then pulls a little too hard
[Music]
Scarlet Witch actress Elizabeth Olsen
took a tumble on set as she shot the
heroines vengeance tinge sequence at the
end of the film the moments happened
while Olsen Scarlett wage was making her
way toward Thanos to enlist a full
capacity of a mystical powers and give
him a piece of her mind
the theatrical version of that scene was
impactful enough to send shivers down
every viewers spines but one takes or
Olsen slip-and-fall before she could
reach the mad Titan the time travel in
Avengers endgame is difficult to wrap
your head around Paul Rudd whose
superhero character ant-man knows plenty
about time travel alternate dimensions
and how to navigate the quantum realm
got a bit flustered while trying to
explain the rules of time-travel as
outlined in endgame two thing about time
travel in another end game I'll take
Captain America actor Chris Evans laughs
over the masky war in 2012 Avengers
which he apparently now thinks as dorky
or maybe uncomfortable I can't believe I
made a whole movie with this thing in
another blooper Captain Marvel star brie
Larson amidst that she doesn't feel cool
while wearing a bald cap and hanging
from a harness for a scene in which her
character is flying look cooler doesn't
feel cool but if it looks cool as we're
shooting a film as monumental as
Avengers ends gamer works up a mighty
appetite and the stars are apparently
thinking of snacks and sugary sodas
while on set you have any idea and it's
coursing through my veins right now
Sun yawns
yes another endgame blooper shows
ancient one portrayer Tilda Swinton
asking for an orange soda while shooting
right on cue up pops a hand with a glass
bottle of the fizzy stuff Thanos wasn't
the only enemy Tony Stark had to face
off against an Avengers ends game actor
Robert Downey jr. faced some trouble
with the automatic trunk of Tony's sleek
sports car while trying to shut it
before heading into Avengers HQ we are
getting from losing his wife and
children and thanasis decimation at the
start of the film to taking on the
moniker Ronin and going on a revenge for
your killing spree and watching his
fellow Avenger Black Widow die in front
of his eyes Hawkeye had a dark storyline
in Avengers endgame however the actor
who plays the sharpshooting hero had a
lot of fun on set
[Music]
the endgame blooper reel ends just as
the infinity saga did with Ironman actor
Robert Downey jr. is the last phase
fantasy in the collection of goof-ups
shown shooting the scene in which he
returns a 2012 New York part of that
portion of the Avengers time heist
mission involved Tony Stark disguising
himself as a law enforcement officer
responding to the chaos and stark tower
while filming that sequence Downey jr.
jokes every take he's delivered has been
flawless and that he simply can't
improve upon perfection we know our DJ
is just being silly but there's some
truth to his quip his Iron Man was the
hero who laid the foundation for the MCU
and without him the Marvel movie world
wouldn't be what it is today I feel like
I've given you all you could ever want
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite MCU flicks are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]